monsieur le premier ministre pendant la
guerre du vietnam le monde entier
s'était moqué d'un commandant américain
accusé d'avoir rasé un village qui a
vécu cette explication bizarre lorsque
nous sommes arrivés l'ennemi était déjà
là pour sauver le village nous avons dû
le détruire aujourd'hui pour sauver le
monde de la pandémie
il a fallu sacrifier l'économie voilà la
situation redoutable dans laquelle vous
entamez votre mandat autant dire qu'on
vous a confié un job à 10000 aspirine
monsieur le premier ministre
mais il faut toujours regarder le bon
côté des choses surtout quand il y en a
pas le temps dont je dispose est
inversement proportionnel à l'ampleur du
sujet je me bornerai à trois réflexions
la première est le mythe de l'état père
noël la france va sortir et saurait de
la crise
les démagogues vont se déchaîner et
d'abord les marchands d'illusions de la
dépense publique illimitée alimenté par
l'improbable quatuor soros minc pigasse
mélenchon qui ont décidé de promouvoir
en commun l'idée qu'il est devenu
ringard de rembourser ses dettes
les rois d'autrefois avait déjà trouvé
une solution qui consistait à trancher
la tête de leurs créanciers le monde est
devenu plus doux aujourd'hui on nous
propose seulement de les ruiner les
économistes s'affrontent désormais là
dessus sur twitter et sur bfm comme les
médecins sur la chloroquine le principal
intérêt de ces débats est de redonner
des lettres de noblesse aux astrologues
mais ce qui est grave c'est que cette
croyance va faire déployer toutes les
banderoles à la rentrée puisqu'elle
implique qu'il n'y a plus de limites au
financement à crédit et à l'infini de
toutes les politiques publiques
elle renforce l'idée bien française que
l'argent public est comme l'eau bénite
et que chacun peut se servir
bien sûr pour l'heure il n'y a pas
d'autre solution que le keynésianisme
sous stéroïdes adoptée par le monde
entier et qui nous a tellement monté en
2009 de la part d'une banque centrale
européenne plus proche d'un club sado
masochistes que de la bouée de sauvetage
qui nous aurait remis à flot
et vous avez et vous avez raison d'y
recourir
mais gardons-nous de confondre plan de
relance et financement de déficit
incontrôlée sinon je la dette que nous
laisserons à nos enfants nous ne devrons
plus être surpris que les bb écrit à la
naissance
je dis cela parce qu'on ne parle à juste
titre que de l'emploi on a parfois
l'impression que certains de nos
concitoyens éprouve quelques peines à
envisager la reprise du travail
la france possède tout de même le seul
syndicat au monde qui a déposé un prévis
de grève le jour du déconfinement et
traîné au tribunal les entreprises qui
redémarrait à grand peine
[Applaudissements]
le président de la république avait
déclaré en avril dernier il n'y a pas
d'argent magique
puissiez vous monsieur le premier
ministre tenir ce cas et expliquer sans
relâche que la clé de la reprise et le
travail pas l'argent tombé du ciel
ma deuxième remarque depuis des
élections municipales nous sommes tous
écolos le bonheur est dans le pré c'est
une excellente nouvelle
mais quelle écologie le tout le monde il
est beau tout le monde il est écolo est
trompeur car il y a deux écologie ge
pourra vous l'avez dire à l'assemblée
monsieur le rhume ni celle de la
croissance et celle de la décroissance
la convention citoyenne a accouché de
trois sortes de mesures des mesures
techniques souvent déjà entreprises
comme la rénovation des logements pas de
problème d'autre part des solutions à la
française qui ne coûte rien proclame des
bons sentiments et rendre les loi
bavarde l'environnement dans la
constitution ou le crime descossy par
exemple elles ne feront que gonfler
encore nos codes qui ressemble déjà à
des scripts culture de jeff koons et
enfin un catalogue de contraintes qui
sont le fonds de commerce des ong
décroissante la décroissance est l'opium
des bobos comme nous l'ont prouvé
réclamant récemment avec éclat en une du
monde dans une proclamation aussi
subversif que du fromage à tartiner une
brochette de stars kérosène au bilan
carbone le plus élevé de la france de la
planète
c'est risible mais ce n'est pas drôle ce
qui est ennuyeux c'est que la convention
s'est gardé de répondre aux questions
essentielles comment parvenir à une
énergie décarbonée
dans l'hypothèse où on décide de se
passer du nucléaire comment faire cesser
l'hypocrisie de l'importation de
millions de tonnes d'eau gm tout en
interdisant les ogm à nos agriculteurs
comment faire payer les émissions de
carbone chez nous et à nos frontières
et surtout quelles sont les pistes pour
la seule solution réaliste au défi
climatique la croissance verte
l'innovation les nouvelles énergies les
startups la recherche et développement
le capital-risque la formation la france
a saboté son industrie saborder son
industrie avec une méthode simple tout
ce qui bouge on le taxe tout ce qui
bouge encore on le réglementent tout ce
qui ne bouge plus on le subventionne
[Applaudissements]
l'europe a raté la grande révolution des
40 dernières années le numérique la
prochaine révolution est celle des
industries de la transition écologique
que notre absence de pétrole devrait
nous faire aborder avec plus d'atouts
que nos concurrents
freiné par les lobbys de l'or noir
l'avenir est là pas dans l'écologie du
gentil avec les arbres méchant avec les
hommes qui ne fait qu'accroître que les
ronds-points votre troisième défi est
celui du régalien
la situation est critique alors que de
nombreuses catégories de français à
commencer par les soignants et les
premiers de corvée ont été admirables
les droits de retrait dans
l'administration ont atteint des sommets
la justice a quasiment suspendu son
activité pendant trois mois
les greffiers n'ayant pas les moyens de
télétravailler mais le dossier le plus
alarmant est celui de la police sa crise
touche aujourd'hui sa légitimité c'est
doctrine d'intervention son organisation
et ses fonctionnaires pas de chance pour
nos policiers après le chewing gum le mc
do les westerns et le rock'n roll on
importe aujourd'hui d'amérique les
névroses sur la race qui n'ont rien à
faire sur nos terres universaliste
[Applaudissements]
et le pauvre policier de banlieue est
désormais traité de porc comme celui de
chicago
il est temps que les politiques les
journalistes les intellectuels et
surtout ceux du camp du bien
terrorisée depuis toujours par la
panique de ne pas être du côté des
victimes prennent conscience que le
racisme n'est pas du côté de ceux qu'on
accuse aujourd'hui mais du côté des faux
anti raciste que sont les racialiste les
indigéniste et les des coloniaux
[Applaudissements]
écoutons la leçon de lucidité d'abdou
salle manning qui nous dit je cite une
image va glacer lors de la manifestation
pour adama traoré un policier noir se
fait harceler par la foule qui lui crie
vendus
t'as pas honte reprocher un homme noir
d'être un policier et qui vaut
exactement à interdire un homme noir
l'accès à la députation à un bar ou un
mariage mixte sous prétexte sa couleur
ce qui résonne dans ce discours c'est la
prison de la victimisation et de
l'essentialisation fin de citation nous
attendons de votre gouvernement qu'il
trouve les mots pour s'opposer à cette
tragi comédie burlesque autant que de
moyens ce dont ont besoin aujourd'hui
les policiers c'est de respect et de
considération
il faut répondre à ceux qui ont décidé
de discréditer la police pour mieux
discréditer l'état que ce qui menace les
français ce sont les terroristes les
criminels les dealers et les bandes
armées de kalachnikov dans les rues ce
n'est pas la police
[Applaudissements]
un dernier mot il ne faut jamais gâcher
une crise disette obama et je voudrais
terminer sur l'immense est paradoxal
opportunités que nous offre celle ci en
saluant l'accord franco allemand sur le
plan de relance européen
si nous arrivons à convaincre nos
partenaires alors la crise du
coronavirus aura pour conséquence un
grand pas en avant de l'europe c'est
pour payer l'énorme dette de la guerre
contre les anglais que les américains
ont pour la première fois rassemblé
leurs états et lancer la marche vers les
états unis d'amérique pour l'europe ce
premier pas en vue de l'harmonisation
financière budgétaire et fiscale est
essentielle nietzsche disait l'europe ne
se fera qu'au bord du tombeau il
prédisait avec une vision prophétique
les guerres à venir et la sagesse de
ceux qui après 1945 ont jeté les bases
de l'union européenne mais sa prophétie
vaut aussi pour notre temps chaque crise
depuis le traité de rome a failli
emporter l'europe et chaque crise la
renforcer celle ci est sans doute la
plus grave et c'est peut-être celle qui
nous fera faire le plus grand pas c'est
le défi qui nous attend
je vous remercie